right now lawmakers carson city are
working into the night
they have until tomorrow to finish two
years worth of work
and some big issues affecting you and
your family remain on the table
eight news now has the only local
television crew on the ground there
the i-team's david charns is live and
david it is crunch time
yeah sasha so they are working right now
and the legislature has until tomorrow
at midnight to get all the work done
this session so that of course means
they will be working on the memorial day
holiday
but a lot has happened in just the past
hour or so this is what i want to tell
you about
the assembly passing that public option
health care bill
it's likely to move forward through the
senate and become law
two other big issues happening right now
first a new excise tax on the mining
industry something we talked to you
about
during our newscast at five and six it's
estimated the proposal would bring in
about 80 million dollars for education
every year
and it's something that the mining
industry is actually in favor of
no piece of legislation is perfect but
we were committed
to designating uh funds for education
we were committed to making sure that we
have stability for our kids for the long
term
another big issue a so-called right to
return proposal
basically allows tens of thousands of
people who were in the tourism industry
working on the strip who were laid off
during the pandemic
to get their jobs back the culinary
union says this also prevents those who
may have been forced into early
retirement or laid off for reasons
unknown during the pandemic to also get
their jobs back
democrats agree with that this passed
along a party lines in the assembly
earlier today but republicans say this
would unfairly affect small businesses
we already have laws that protect our
employees if they feel they're being
discriminated against
and keep in mind all the large pretty
much
all the large bargaining agreements
collective bargaining agreements that i
know
have a right to return work policy
the right to return likely to become law
the mining tax needs a two-thirds
majority to pass in
either house here so we'll see what
happens with that tomorrow
public option we're talking election
laws a lot could happen in the next 24
hours
we'll keep you posted here live in
carson city tonight i'm david charns 8
news now